Ця машина виконує роботу кількох будівельників.
Вона укладає бетон шарами і може звести 4 квадратних метри
стіни за годину. Так будується найбільша в Європі надрукована
на 3D-принтері споруда – промислова будівля без вікон.
Керівник будмайданчика Чікаезе Угву з Нігерії, який навчався
в Німеччині, задоволений прогресом.
Коли йдеться про такі складні будівлі, як ця, із такою архітектурою
- з хвилястими стінами й особливими формами - то ми працюємо
більш ніж утричі швидше, ніж звичайне будівництво.
Бетону у силосі вистачає на 2 дні. Звідси він надходить
у друкувальну голівку, яка рухається заданою траєкторією.
Процес не просто швидший – він також вимагає менше
матеріалів і працівників. А ще тут чистіше, ніж на звичайних
будівельних майданчиках.
Аби звести цю красиву будівлю, нам потрібні лише троє людей.
Одна людина керує принтером, інша – бетонозмішувачем.
І ще одна людина має ходити й контролювати, чи все гаразд,
а також вставляти анкери для бетону. Цим займаюся я.
Як керівник будівельного майданчика, він відповідає
за перевірку бетономішалки.
А також займається офісною роботою на своєму смартфоні.
У проміжках будівельники кріплять анкери – скріплювальні
металічні зв’язки - для підтримки подвійних стінок.
Його колега спостерігає за роботою 3D-принтера на екрані комп’ютера.
Але як 3D-принтер знає, що друкувати?
По суті процес полягає в тому, що архітектор проєктує
будівлю з нашою допомогою. Ми кажемо йому, що можливо
зробити, а що ні. Після створення дизайну він дає нам покроковий файл,
який є центральною лінією будівлі. Ми поетапно відправляємо його
на слайдер. Потім нарізаємо. Тоді ми отримуємо код G.
Ми відправляємо його на принтер і починаємо друкувати.
Німецька компанія Peri побудувала будівлю за допомогою
3D-принтера BOD2 данської компанії Cobod.
Цементні стелі конструкції заливаються звичайним способом
і підтримуються, поки бетон не висохне.
Будівництво такої споруди займає пів року.
Її довжина 54 метри, ширина 11 метрів і висота 9 метрів.
Будівля не потребує вікон, тому що в ній розмістяться
лише комп’ютерні сервери.
Архітектор Ян Фолькман спроєктував цю найбільшу
та найвищу будівлю, надруковану на 3D.
Це стало можливим завдяки використанню сталевих балок
- нової розробки в 3D-конструюванні.
Особлива привабливість полягає в тому, що ви можете експериментувати
з цим методом будівництва та дізнатися, що саме ви можете створити
в рамках деяких дуже простих архітектурних вимог.
Це неможливо з жодною іншою технологією. Саме це спонукало нас.
Власником і забудовником є агент з нерухомості, який хотів
побудувати щось нове та інноваційне на знаковому місці.
Ціна була високою, тому йому потрібно було знати, що це принесе прибуток.
Загалом ми вклали сюди 2,5 млн євро включно із землею.
Я не можу вам сказати, скільки б це коштувало, якби ми будували
традиційним способом, тому що ми доволі швидко перейшли на 3D-друк.
Я просто хотів знати: чи можу я зробити це економічно вигідніше
за допомогою 3D-друку? І я зміг.
Менеджеру також доводиться виконувати частину роботи вручну,
особливо в місцях зупинки та запуску принтера.
Можливо, йому доведеться внести невеликі корективи в роботу,
але він не хоче повертатися до традиційного будівництва.
Я справді не думаю, що повернуся на звичайний будівельний майданчик.
Але ніхто не знає майбутнього. Я справді вірю, що тривимірний друк
розвиватиметься і ростиме.
Тому я думаю, що залишуся працювати із друком у 3D.
Будівництво за допомогою 3D-принтерів швидко виходить
з експериментальної фази на комерційний ринок.
Що стосується Чікаезе Угву, то він і його принтер мають
достатньо контрактів на будівництво на наступні два роки.